[Music]
hey guys i'm matt welcome back to my
kitchen
a few months ago my friend shreya from
buzzfeed india challenged me to try
maggie noodles for the first time
and then make an original recipe with
them so what i did was take
instant noodles and turn them into an
unnecessarily complicated and
time-consuming sandwich
why has he made a two-minute recipe into
a 20-minute recipe
i've learned a lot since then which is
good because now i have been issued
yet another challenge this time from the
philippines hey matt my name is jessica
i am from manila and today i'm very
excited to introduce to you
a filipino favorite ingredient slash
condiment and that is none other than
the vago ong or the fermented shrimp
paste the one i have here is the regular
ginisang bagong it also comes in
different
flavors so there's sweet there's spicy
and if you can't make up your mind
there's also sweet and spicy
normally we would have this as a dip for
our green mangoes
our boiled vegetables we also add them
in our dishes with pork with stir-fried
vegetables
with other meat we also add them to our
rice as fried rice like bago on fried
rice oh my gosh i'm so hungry so i
challenge you matt
to create your own bhagawang dish using
your creative chef mind and i'm going to
try to remake that here with my very
limited
cooking skills and let's see if my
filipino palette approves
also a word of caution this does smell
really bad especially when you're
cooking it so it's gonna
smell pretty much everywhere i would
apologize to your neighbors if you live
in
like a condo or apartment but it's all
worth it it's all worth it i promise you
already cheska challenge accepted i'm
gonna go and try and find the salty
stinky condiment
[Music]
here it is in all of its glory this is
gina sang
bhagawang there's some oil on the top
there you can see like what i think are
the little shrimp floating inside
let's give it a shot there we go
it's very stinky it's definitely sort of
fishy it's got that ocean smell
it's a little bit anxious it's got it's
got like
i don't know how to describe it's got
like a huh to it let's give it a taste
three two one
wow definitely salty umami my plan is to
make a few dishes use it see how it's
supposed to be used what it's supposed
to pair with
so i went ahead and tried three
different recipes just to sort of see
the range of what you could make and to
gain a better understanding of it first
and foremost i just have some green
mangoes that i'm going to dip in it
then i have a bag on fried rice and then
finally i have this pork belly stew
i have the green unripe mangoes that
looks like a generous helping
this works very well together the mango
is nice and crunchy but that pairs super
super well with the saltiness of the
bhagwon
and now we have the fried rice
it adds like a nice saltiness to it wow
i love that that's my favorite so far
all right now let's try the stewed pork
these two man are so good when you eat
it it warms you all the way down it's
like not
too spicy but it's like just enough that
you're like oh hello you're there this
is going to take a little thought i need
to
meditate a bit see what bagloon would
fit well in and when i come back i'll
kind of have an idea and let's see what
we can whip up
[Music]
welcome back it is day two i had to take
the night to think about things
i liked all the dishes i tried yesterday
but what really got me was how
unique bhagwong is it's so strong it's
so fishy it adds
such a unique flavor to things which
then got me thinking
about anchovies another salty fishy
ingredient that i cook with a lot and
then that got me thinking about putin
esca and so
that's what i think i'm going to
experiment with today making a bagawong
putin esca to get started my pan is
preheating over medium medium high heat
and i'm adding olive oil now i am adding
onions and garlic give that a nice stir
everyone gets nice and coated in the oil
and i'm letting this cook for a few
minutes just until the onions are nice
and softened
that looks excellent now i'm adding some
capers for a little bit of brininess
some red pepper flake for heat and
finally my
baguong i'm gonna go with
one tablespoon
i'm gonna go with two tablespoons that
feels right to me
it's disintegrated and broken up really
nicely into the sauce i'm just gonna let
this cook for a few more minutes and
then check back in
and now that i have this nice umami
spicy fishy
briny oil it is time to add the crushed
tomatoes
stir and let that cook down for a few
minutes
my sauce is looking great my pasta is
cooking for about one minute shy of the
package instructions i just want to give
it a little taste
make sure everything is working
i don't really taste it
call it three okay
oh
now it reads for me everything feels
pretty balanced to me
so i'm just going to add my last two
ingredients my chopped olives
and oregano nice stir
before i get rid of my pasta reserve
like
half a cup of water add my pasta
and i am at capacity and very gently
stir it in and i'm going to add
my pasta water just get everything to
loosen
up the starch in the water is going to
help the sauce cling to the pasta it's
going to help it thicken up a little bit
and there we have it putnesska
here goes nothing see how i did
honestly i'm really pleased with how
this turned out you can taste like the
fishiness from the bug long and adds a
little bit of umami to it it adds a nice
saltiness to it
goes with the capers and olives it's got
a little spice to it i would
probably make this again i'd be more
inclined to make this again because they
sell bagong in giant jars
and they sell anchovies and little teeny
packages unfortunately i am not the
judge of this
i am going to send my recipe back to
cheska to see what she thinks
and hopefully she likes my bhagavan
putnezka
so i just finished uh recreating matt's
recipe
uh on the bagong so i just made this
bago-ong
pasta i was very nervous to make it at
first one because i've never made pasta
in my life
while i was making the sauce i made it a
point to try it every now and then
and i couldn't really taste the pagong
so much
so i added like two more tablespoons
okay
so i guess now is the moment of truth
i'm gonna give my honest feedback
oh good but i would probably add another
bungalow online there
another dollop of boku-on no
she said there's not enough as far as
pastas are concerned this is a pretty
good dish
but if you would tell me that it had
bagoong in there
it didn't feel like it was the star of
the show
if you disagree with how i thought of
this dish please let me know in the
comments below or you can take it to me
personally
on my instagram at franchiseall but
thank you so much matt for giving me
this opportunity to exchange cultures
with you
bye no hard feelings jessica he'll be
around too
hello i'm jumping back on here so i just
had dinner with my family and i just
wanted to do like a follow-up
and some of them actually tasted the
bhagawang
in the dish my brother-in-law found it
uh too salty probably because i added
too much pagong but my father-in-law
thought that it was perfect i guess it's
the preference and what you're expecting
from the dish
so bye matt
oh yes
[Music]